sorry it's good i'm sorry you want me
dead no i don't
i just asked you yeah yeah so you're so
your son any problems with him oh my god
bobby won't you cut off this topic i
don't want to
last any problems with him no nice great
he's got a
99th percentile head because he's half
korean so uh
okay how about you gilbert so how you're
getting married i
uh congrats i got engaged i uh
i know that inspired by george kimmel
and i did it just pulled the trigger
and so when is that going to happen her
her parents wishes are don't do it any
time soon
oh god because of covet they would want
like
family from countries all right yeah
wait a couple years but i'm thinking uh
we would do it in hawaii so everyone's
gonna have a fun trip yeah um
well destination weddings are a little
bit tricky but i think that you is there
anything
is there any scenario
is there any other scenario in the
future that it wouldn't happen
like what no that the wedding's off no
there's no scenario no there's a
scenario would that would have happened
in that four years
that was the tumultuous part was getting
to know each other
all the therapy we're going to give you
another scenario okay let me just give
you a scenario but be a doctor in this
situation no
i'm not a doctor i'm a producer
i'm going to stay with my wife all right
you don't even hear my [ __ ] thing
you're going to say like borderlands 2.
no no i'm not embarrassed no just listen
to my [ __ ] deal okay
take the meeting okay wait you got to
take the meet with the producer give me
like i need a senior
name what company my name is um
john leibowitz very familiar
john leibowitz standard yeah and i work
for
sh kaboom kaboom productions
oh john lee was a kaboom production
cleaning product
all right there we go
production there's money there so come
into the meeting hey gilbert sit down oh
thanks man
huge fan of your work in fact you know i
just think that there would be no tiger
belly without you
oh don't tell bobby he's terrible but
the foundation is definitely you and uh
thank you you know i listen every week
and
my family listens every week because of
you you're great thank you and i i just
big fan yeah and you know i looked at
your um all your work
your youtube work and i saw what i saw
i saw some of your chicago work too
right thank you yeah
when you were singing that song oh damn
well you were gay it was gained a little
weight yeah
i'm getting
and also um give it to him straight babe
i'm going to tell you i'm sorry do you
have another producer here yes are you
wait are you the seed planter
i am it's they see yes so anyway i want
to just
cut to the chase um we want to what we
want to do is we
we have all these um franchises you know
we've got the uh the rights and the ip
of
ip is that the right word of uh some of
these franchises and we want to make
huge movies
and we just don't like your wife or your
fiance my fiance
yeah and we just think that because we
want you to make you a leading man
what's your name
we don't know that's how oh so you don't
that's how much i didn't
like or not you know yeah yeah yeah okay
interesting i don't like your tone i'm a
producer john liebow it's here uh you're
a fan of you're a fan of my work
i'm the heart and soul thank you for the
meeting okay the beating
i'll see you later i'm okay i'm sorry
let me hear your i apologize you don't
talk to a producer like that
i'm sorry you can talk to him any which
way you want guild thank you seed
planter
okay we want you to be the lead we don't
want you to be married we
we want you to be single and um you know
in order for this deal to go through we
give you a six picture deal
oh that does sound yeah and and these
are 200 million dollar movies and you
know okay and we have chris pratt
on a couple of them favorite yeah yeah
we've got um
but you're billed first you're built
first above chris
yeah above christmas the rock yeah in a
couple of them
he's gonna play the nemesis you'll
you're build first um
so in order for you to sign the six
pitcher deal also
plus you're get you're gonna make points
on the movie the back end
love it and we're also gonna give you 20
million dollars a movie
wow that's almost as much as yeah yeah
yeah 27 that's
uh 20 times six you did the math can you
do it i don't know how to i don't eat
that we don't know yet i feel because
because i don't know
your fiance she's gonna be like take the
[ __ ] deal i'll meet you
ten years from now in taiwan that's kind
of how you would play
swimming as a [ __ ] billionaire we
can't catch you with her in anything or
the deal's through
we can't catch you with her in any
public setting
you know you run a tough bargain yeah
john this is really interesting so
we'll give you six hours to decide sure
all right so what are you gonna do so on
this six hours please play cindy
oh okay wait are you telling me yeah
okay hey
fiance yeah what did they say so
literally i'll just put out there they
won't offer me all this money it's 60
times it's 20 times six i don't know how
much that is but it's a lot of money
i'm gonna be billed above chris pratt
your favorite uh
i love that we cannot be together
anymore i mean what is it i would
i would be willing to be with you still
and turn this down
my life's dream are you okay with that
i mean what does that even mean are we
going to be able to like have sex hold
hands
we cannot have i didn't ask about one
second john yeah
can i have sex with can i have no i
can't have sex with you
i can't have sex you will never see this
foreskin again
and for how many years 10 years
take the deal will i will you will you
wait for me
um yeah i'll take that as a yeah
hey john i'll sign the papers yeah okay
good uh if i'm being yeah we would
i would talk to her yeah but she's and
there is
there is a yeah there is a way
hey want to kill your baby leave your
wife who are you say
sorry i'm sorry guys i like devil's
advocate though it's good yeah
i'm just having to i'm trying i'm i'm
testing you know
that's true your morality and your value
system i already
if it was turned on you and that same
question was posed
i don't even it'd be the quickest
decision of your life no that's not true
yes i'll tell you why it's not true i
can tell you why it's not true
because at the level that i'm at now
is exactly where i want to be
there's nothing that's above it that i'm
interested in
or i desire i don't want it i don't want
to be like
like kevin couldn't hang out in any of
our lunches or anything like that
just because of security reasons and
what oh wow like he's
he just wasn't around he's so busy too
yeah that he's doing like
i don't know at six o'clock i have to do
my radio show from six to
eleven and then i have to do rewrites i
mean just he's just constantly busy
he's he's like the rock i heard the rock
is like that as well right
and it's like work comes for i i'm not
like that i'm made i'm not made up like
that i don't want that
this is the level that i want i love the
fans listening right now
i love you guys i really do i [ __ ]
love you guys
i love where i'm at so it's like no i
wouldn't take it
why would i need i i feel like a
millionaire as it is
yeah because i am one uh
borderlands i'm kidding i'm kidding but
you know what i mean
i'm kidding i want to set the record
straight
i got no money i got no money i want to
set the record straight about something
on bad friends you said that there's
this
new guy who came into our lives
right and you painted him out to be
somebody
that like it's just new and random and
then andrew suggested it it was someone
that i
dated and i just want to set the record
straight